Paco has evolutionalized
his application
with more features.
In the process,
he has structured
and organized the code
using the WebApp2 framework.
Until now, all his work
has been concentrated
in Python root code files,
where there are
also html fragments
in the form
of embedded chain text.
As a result, the html content
mixed with root code
tends to easily
become disorganized
and makes application
maintenance difficult.
This problem is solved
by incorporating
a template engine.
This will help us to maintain
an organized file structure
as well as providing us
with friendly syntax
for interacting with html
content variables and blocks.
It will also help us
to separate responsibilities.
For example,
Paco's team designer
will only have access
to the templates,
but not the source code.
He will be able to use
familiar tools
to edit and design html.
There are many
template engines for Python.
Jinja2 is one of the most used.
It's syntax is simple, clear
and also expressive.
And it comes included
with Google App Engine SDK.
In this lesson,
we will incorporate
the census application
with Jinja2 templates,
and we will change
the structure of existing code
to separate
the visual presentation
and the functional logic
into levels.
Since Jinja 2
is an included library,
Paco modifies the library section
in the file app.yaml,
adding the latest version
of Jinja2.
With this addition,
Paco will be able to call
the classes and functions
of the latest available version
of Jinja2
directly from
his application code.
In Jinja2 there's
a central environment object
that will indicate
the configuration total objects
and that will be used to upload
file system templates to memory.
Paco creates this object
by starting the file main.py
before defining the handlers
since they will be used.
As a good safety procedure,
upon starting
the environment,
an extension will be prepared
to activate the autoescape
upon rendering values.
On occasions the textual value
of a variable
needs to be modified.
For example, the use
of uppercase and lowercase
in chains of text,
or the format
of numerical values.
For this,
Jinja2 provides the filters.
Paco modifies the handler
identitypage.get
by moving the text that
was printing in the response
to a new separate html file
called identity_form.html
in the template directory
where, from now on,
templates will be found.
This template
contains the format
for identifying users.
But Paco also wants
to show the current date
and the list
of types of documents
that he defined as a constant.
To do this, Paco needs to
upload the environment template
calling the method Get Template,
passing as a parameter
the name of the recently
created file.
Paco will combine the template
that defines two variables
with the dynamic data
generated by the application,
calling the render method
and passing a dictionary
with the pairs as parameter.
The dictionary defines
the names of the variables
in they keys
and their respective values.
In our case,
the current date calculated
with the standard library
and the constant
with the types of documents.
The templates in Jija2 not only
have ordinary html,
they also have instructions
using a special syntax
that Paco needs
to become familiar with.
The variables found
between double brackets
are going to be transformed
to their textual value.
So, upon adding this expression,
the date will be displayed
that previously passed
to the template as a variable.
As for the dictionary
with the types of documents,
it's different, since it needs
to run each of the items,
showing them as options
on the list.
The control structure For
included in Jina2
allows this.
The syntax in this case
consists in surrounding
the whole sentence
between blocks
with this structure.
The interaction
of the dictionary is similar
to how code
would be done in Python.
There are also
conditional control structures
with If and Else.
To show one section or another
depending
on the expression value,
Paco will use it to show
a message of success
confirming the entered data
when the checkbox is selected,
and a message of error
when not selected.
The filters are applied
to the variables
separated by
the backslash character
and can have parameters
between parentheses.
Multiple filters
can be linked together,
applying one filter
to the next.
Jinja2 includes various useful
filters that are commonly used,
however, it is also possible
to create personalized filters
according to our needs.
Paco notices that the items
on the document type list
are not in order,
so he decides to apply
the dicsort filter to do it.
With the template
files finished,
Paco begins to realize
that they all have
sections in common,
such as the heading
and the footer.
To make changes
in these sections
he needs to update
each one of the files
with the new information.
This proves to be inefficient,
prone to errors
and tends to lose consistency
throughout the site.
To avoid this scenario,
Jinja2 offers Paco
template inheritance,
which allows him to build
a base skeleton template
that contains the common
elements of the site
and defines blocks
that the younger templates
can write over.
Paco creates a new file that
will serve as the base template
with the name base.html.
There the html skeleton
structure is defined
that all the templates
have in common,
as well as the sections or
blocks that can be overwritten
defined with
the block directive.
Existing templates
now need to be inherited
from this base template.
To do this, they start
with the extense directive
and for each one of the sections
to be overwritten
the same directive block
will be used again
with the appropriate content.
In case it's not provided,
the content written
on the base template
will be used as default.
By using templates,
Paco's team
is even more productive.
It's easier to work as a team
and make less mistakes
by having the visual presentation
separated from
the functional logic.
For example, the designer
will be exclusively in charge of
editing the template html files
while Paco
and the other developers
will be in charge
of the Python code.
However, the price model
for Google App Engine
functions as
a low demand scheme,
meaning, only the resources
consumed are charged.
We have covered the basic
sections of Google App Engine.
With what you have learned
in this version of Hackademy
you will be able to create
simple applications
on this platform.
We invite you to explore
the official documents
and you will discover
that they will allow you
to bring your application
to the next level.
Thank you for joining us
in this course.
We are David and Maciek,
experts in web application
development.
We'll see you next time.
Keep programming!